[Music]
matt joins us in modesto california matt
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how you guys doing great how can we
help
um yeah so i have a little bit of a car
situation um
given this current market
i'm able to
have my car paid off
uh currently i owe about 18 000 on it
the only issue is i i don't have
a solution for another vehicle if i were
to do that
um so i thought i'd call you guys and
pick your brand get some ideas okay so
how much could you get for the car if
you sold today
i can get about 18
100.
so about what you owe
correct
all right so that would leave you with
pretty much net zero
pretty much yeah do you have any money
in savings
uh just the uh thousand dollar emergency
fund okay and do you have any other debt
uh yes we're currently step two so we
have uh we have another vehicle credit
card um
personal loans
okay and you have another vehicle you
said you have another car payment but
you're just looking at this one right
now
yes the other one's uh my wife's um
she's a little bit more reluctant to
sell at this point so
i'm kind of the one uh open to taking
the hit as far as getting a less
expensive vehicle what do you owe on
that one and what would it sell for
today
uh i believe we owe 23 000 on that one
and
i haven't looked at the value in a while
but
last time i looked up they were
offering you know a few thousand more
than than what it was yeah that's why i
asked i'm just wondering uh and part of
this is getting your wife on the same
page is she on board with the baby steps
oh absolutely yeah we've been going
through debt um through the debt
snowball um it's just her car
you know it's a big expense and it's you
know of course it's got brand new and
the warranty and it makes her feel
safe um
so that's why i'm the one more willing
to
sell my car and kind of help speed
things up how much do you guys make matt
a year
uh we both make about 84 000. okay
um
yeah i mean it's it's a
it's a lot of car
uh when it gets to be about 50 of
your household income it it starts to be
a lot um
so i would be in favor of
selling
um just to get this off your plates but
that would require
a different options right you could
pause the debt snowball save up a little
bit of cash
and get what we'd call the beater like
the not so fun few thousand dollar car
um
but you're eighteen thousand dollars
lighter in debt um to do that
um if you guy what other debt do you
have you have the two cars
what else was that you said
uh two cars uh we have a personal loan
to about 3 500
we have about
uh maybe seven grand in credit cards
okay
um
yeah that i mean that that that's where
i would lean if i was in your shoes and
i would really love her i understand the
feeling of
being secure and the new car the
warranty all of that but
it may give her a little bit of
ease
to go and even just look at some used
cars
uh even suvs because they're not as bad
again i think people have the word used
in their head and have a stereotype with
it but when you go and look they're not
as unsafe feeling as you would probably
imagine i mean i just feel that i just
feel the weight of these cars right like
if you guys were making 150 a year and
you know you can knock them out but
i just i just want to see you guys
drowning in
car debt yeah when you've got 41 000 in
cars making 84 and you've got a pile of
debt it's just that's a tough tight
situation so there's going to be you
need to make some sacrifices here that
might mean taking on some side jobs
selling your car and selling other stuff
but what you need right now is to stack
up cash quick and so
i'm gonna have a conversation with the
wife about selling this car if you can
make money from the deal and try to
clean up some of this debt because
remember you clean up those two car
payments you know have more money in
your bank every month that you can use
to attack more debt to save up more and
so maybe run some numbers with her
whatever you might think might connect
with her personality style but there's
going to be sacrifices need to be made
and if she's not willing to make him and
it's all on you that's going to put a
strain on the relationship on your end
yeah no it
definitely can i'm i'm uh
you know trying to compromise by
just me doing it um but no i and
hopefully by me and doing this it helps
kind of spur on something
um so i mean we've touched on it briefly
but it wasn't something i'm just trying
to
press too hard right now but hopefully
she comes around and is more open to the
idea you know maybe in a few months yeah
well back to your question i'm probably
gonna try to save up
three thousand dollars and i'm gonna go
to
a reputable dealer in my area i'm going
to look on craigslist and facebook
marketplace and whatever you do make
sure you do get inspected inspected by a
great mechanic who can you know point
out any issues because the the biggest
fear everyone has rachel is what if i
get a 3 000 car and i have 4 000 worth
of repairs in the first month right and
the truth is there's a lot of i think a
lot of it comes down to justification of
why i don't want to do the thing
um but
the truth is cars are more reliable go
get go get you an old honda an old
toyota with 200 000 miles and it's going
to get you from a to b and it's not
going to look pretty but it's going to
give you some motivation to get out of
debt the worst car you drive the more
motivation you're going to have to get
rid of this debt and so that's why i
don't love her driving this shiny new
car because it's going to get her
comfortable and you already told me
she's she's very comfortable with this
situation in this car and i want a
little more fire from her and you on the
situation clearly you're wanting to do
whatever it takes to get out
and i applaud you for that so start to
save up some cash as fast as you can if
it means pausing the snowball for a
month that's fine but i don't want you
to go well we haven't done the snowball
in six months because we're saving up
for the car yeah you know and so i just
i think you're gonna need to make some
sacrifices and if she's unwilling to do
that there needs to be a harder
conversation
yeah and there's always just i mean kind
of echoing what you're saying george
though the
we find the deeper you're willing to
sacrifice
whether that's time because you're
taking on an extra job whether that's
lifestyle the faster you're able to get
out of debt and honestly the faster
you're just on the other side of this
you know the sacrifices it's for a short
period of time it's not going to it's
not going to take too long especially if
you guys get rid of these cars you're
able to knock out the 35 000
or 30 500 loans 7000 credit cards i mean
you can make a lot of progress very very
quickly
and then get some emergency funds and
then from there it's like okay you can
take a take a breath
and then go and buy another car like you
can still upgrade um that will never not
happen in your life yeah but it's just
how do we clean it up as fast as
possible to get to point a to point b as
quick as possible and
it's just you guys just have a lot of
car yeah and true security is not coming
from a 23 thousand dollars in car debt
it's coming from being debt-free yeah
that's the security that i want for her
thanks for the call